so I'm incredibly blown away cuz I'm
here with Supergirl this is insane I've
watched all the seasons I'm one of those
dudes who actually watches this though I
love you in it
your characters grown so much over the
last few seasons how he's exciting like
as an actress you know when you get on
these show sometimes you want to kind of
break free and and do some different
things but it seems like they're giving
you so much to explore emotionally and
in relationships wise how exciting is
that for you I feel really lucky with
what I've gotten to do on the show I'm
so proud how much Cara and Supergirl
have matured and that was the one thing
that I cared about everyone's always
asking me what I want to do on the show
but the one thing I care about is that
every season you see growth and you see
her kind of coming into her femininity
and exploring even more what it means to
be a woman we got a costume change now
everyone's making a huge deal out of it
so excited about it it is a big deal how
much input did you have on this on the
costume and the reasons why I got
green-lighted well we've been wanting it
for a while now a couple of writers in
the writers room we've always talked
about it and it kind of it gets really
cold in Vancouver so it was also
practical reasons that I was like guys I
think it's time and I had some input I
got to I send a lot of pictures that
were inspiration and we followed a lot
of the same lines this is the new 52
suit even though she wears she doesn't
wear pants and that iteration but I did
have some input what can we look forward
to in the next season it's um it's our
season next years I was really proud of
this last season season four because it
was so topical and we're doing a bit
more of that this season with technology
and how much were on our phones and our
devices and how that's affecting society
so I'm excited I'm proud of this season
as well we're proud of you thank you so
much but let's appreciate the time enjoy
the show you too